that's why we go to Mike Florio now
because my can help us and tell us about
this cowboy's Giants walkie-talkie
situation what what answers would you
like to have or what questions would you
ask about this well I want to know why
the penalty would only be a fine if it's
true that the Giants were using a walkie
talkie to communicate with Eli Manning
into his into his helmet I have it did
you if its draft picks and suspensions
for air pressure and footballs why is it
different if you're using a walkie
talkie when you shouldn't be and it was
brazen I saw during the game and I
didn't think anything of it because
surely you wouldn't be so brazenly using
a walkie talkie if you shouldn't be
using a walkie-talkie so I'd want to
know why the penalty that they're
talking about is only a fine that's my
first question any chance that ben
mcadoo didn't know that he was breaking
a rule well I'm sure there's a chance he
didn't know but that that that usually
doesn't matter if you're breaking a rule
you're breaking a rule and the teams are
supposed to know what the rules are
especially when it comes to the
technology that can and can't be
employed during a game is this cheating
well I don't know anytime you deliver it
wow if you deliberately break the rules
it's cheating if you accidentally break
the rules what is it I don't know but
didn't ray farmer when he was the Browns
GM get suspended like four weeks for
texting to the sideline out during a
game so yeah I mean rules are the rules
and I I think that its a bright line its
strict liability just like with peds for
players since the Commissioner wanted to
compare what Tom Brady did to P ed use
doesn't matter whether you knew it or
not you have a substance in your body
that violates the rules are suspended no
questions asked whether it was
accidental intentional or or just a
fluke it's it's it's a violation and
you're you're down for four games ok I
have to I'm trying to understand this
and nobody's explained it to me in a
coherent way apparently the Giants
Steelers when they found out there were
a couple of footballs that were
under-inflated they didn't file a formal
protest there for the NFL was not
investigating nobody filed a formal
protest on the walkie talkies used by
the Giants against the Cowboys but the
NFL is investigating now it right yeah
well here's the thing
the NFL issue that press release after
Jay Glazer reported on deflategate two
and it was a masterful response because
it got everyone to move on quickly
because I think a lot of people in the
media did not want to go back down that
rabbit hole so okay hey no formal
complaint nothing to see here thank God
we don't have to talk about air pressure
and footballs again but the NFL I think
specifically worded its release to try
to get people to move on because the
reality is the Giants did raise a
concern the Commissioner acknowledged it
on Wednesday and actually at one point
on Wednesday when he was meeting with
reporters after the league meetings in
Dallas he said the Giants raised the
concern during the game yes which raised
a tremendous red flag because why didn't
you do exactly what you did when the
colts raised the concern about the
Patriots footballs you take them all in
and you measure the footballs and you
see what the PSIs are and the NFL
reached out to me afterward and said the
Commissioner misspoke the Giants raised
the concern after the game which makes
no sense if that's what the Giants did
because after the game there's nothing
you can do about it if the game is over
everybody's gone there's no way to
reconstruct the evidence the air
pressure has changed again in the
footballs a chain of command is big
Chain of Custody rather's been broken so
it doesn't make sense to raise them a
plane after the game and it doesn't make
sense that the NFL didn't take action if
the complaint was raised during the game
Mike Florio profootballtalk.com joining
us Dan Patrick show you're a lawyer can
you translate this from the Commissioner
what I'm aware of Bob eNOS is that the
protocols we went back look to make sure
that the protocols were followed
properly they were the Giants had asked
us about it during the game we went back
we checked that they were properly
followed so all of the league protocols
being properly followed there's no
further follow-up on that yeah that
means that if we begin the process of
explaining why the Giants detected the
two of the Steelers footballs were below
12.5 psi because it was cold in
Pittsburgh that day we will exonerate
the same 23 months after the fact I mean
that's what this is all about yes there
is and that's why they've been doing the
spot checks now for the last two seasons
and if all the protocols are followed
you don't do the spot checks because
you're following the protocols there's
no reason for anybody begin
their hands on the footballs and
deflating them they don't release the
numbers dan because they know on cold
days if you start at 12 5 the PSIs will
be lower than 12 5 they'll be in the 11s
they'll be in a range where if you take
all the PSIs from the games on a cold
day and you compare them to the PS eyes
that were in the Ted wells report people
are going to look at it and say well
these numbers are the same and that's
what they're trying to avoid and that's
the thing that continues to bother me
the most about it they know in their
hearts that they screwed it up they know
it they weren't aware the ideal gas law
somehow when they got the numbers they
concluded that there was cheating and
they spent months working backward to
prove it they hired a scientific firm
with a reputation for and there's a lot
of companies like this out there
whatever opinion you need if you're
going to pay us we'll find a way to give
you that opinion they came to the
conclusion that there was cheating and
they did what they wanted to do and
that's where they went wrong from the
beginning when they decided that it was
a violation and they were going to prove
it instead of let's just get to the
truth and I think a lot of what we see
now is an effort to never have to
revisit that and admit that they got it
wrong thank you Michael C on Sunday all
right Dan see buddy the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]